hey everyone the three of us just played
four hours of cyberpunk
each we all picked different life paths
and we all played slightly differently
in this video we're gonna go
over what differences we encountered
during our play demo
so let's start with ed so i went with
corpo
it starts off with you throwing up in a
sink and your initial story
is um you're a counterintelligence
operative
and your boss wants to sort of take down
his boss
unfortunately um the higher ups get wind
of it and you end up
getting your life to basically like
taunt to shreds like all of your money
like all of your like insurance
your entire life that's been supported
by this corporate job of yours
is gone and you end up on the street
basically from uh starting from scratch
you're already friends with uh your
partner jackie at this point
and so he kind of helps you out and
helps you get back on your feet
and then tomorrow you picked the street
rat or the street kid
street kid yeah i'm so my one i start
off in a
bar um and the street kid has got some
connections and it's like
street street weary and wiley um and
is uh from night city or
treats it like home and helps out one of
the bartenders at the bar
who's got a ongoing debt towards one of
the fixers
and he kind of asks you to go speak to
the fixer and try and
help out and alleviate or get his debt
settled entirely
so you go and do that and you have an
argument with this fixer who's an
out-of-towner and you kind of throw your
weight around as a local
he shows you like there's some magazine
and there's a sports car on there and
he's like steal that
sports car it's top of the line it will
clear the debt so you go over
you get pointed to the right direction
by his inside man and then you start
stealing
um and the moment you start getting the
car like this hand comes through the
window and tells you to get out
and obviously you kind of like pull away
and try to use the device
the device doesn't work you get pulled
out of the car you're about to get
beaten up but then the cops show up
and they kind of put both of you to the
ground and then someone like an elite or
one percenter shows up and is like it's
not worth wasting your time
throw them both out um so you get
chucked out onto the street the person
who pulled you out of the car was jackie
and he's like that's how you meet i was
told
there's a montage that shows your
progression through the years it wasn't
actually in our my demo um i'm not sure
if it was any of yours but
effectively it's kind of like a we were
told like a an animated sequence of some
sort
um or a cinematic sequence that kind of
shows that you guys stuck together for a
while did a bunch of jobs you had a
history and then you pick up with the
main story
yeah so i played the nomad path and the
nomad
path begins with your character v
tearing off
the i don't know the the the badge of
their clan and heading into night city
in order to smuggle something into the
city
and your car breaks down in this small
town out way outside of night city in
this desert town
and you're trying to repair your car you
repair your car to meet your contact
who has the thing that you're trying to
smuggle in turns out to be jackie
you meet him talk with him a little bit
and then you and jackie head to the
border
where you have to get out of the car and
they do an inspection
uh and you have to talk to a uh uh i
guess a border agent
i would say and they ask you some
questions
hop back in the car and then as you're
driving
there's a roadblock that they've set up
and then there's a fire fight that
happens and
eventually that section ends and then
apparently we'd get the cutscene too
that would lead you into how the game
starts and then once you've done those
introductions it sounds like
the game for the most part is very
similar
like all three paths kind of merged now
sit down and tell me what's good your
shorts and or not
it's good to see you too jack how you
been so
with that out of the way how did you
guys play
i i like to speak into like handguns
specifically um
handguns and melee and stealth
um and i found that i ended up relying
on my handgun a lot
because given that this is so early in
the game a lot of the stealth skills
that are actually useful aren't
available to you unless you unlock them
as perks
so i found myself failing stealth a lot
and ending up in a lot of fire fights
yeah so i i put together one of the
classic like i don't know what i'm doing
trash bills
where i like i was just like oh how do i
usually play and
i i didn't learn the lesson that ed
clearly did very quickly so
obviously ed is always smarter than me
um but like i did the thing where i
expect him to stealth and specced into
cool and body so i was like
i can be sneaky and i can talk my way
out of things and
have a bit of charisma obviously i
didn't think about the fact that it
would take a while for that to come into
full
effect so ended up being a kind of
a run-and-gun kick the door in type
person who is clearly incapable of doing
it because i'm respect towards stealth
so i created like a bumbling idiot of a
v
but it still it didn't lock me out of
anything i was still quite capable like
in firefights i was winning
it's important to know that if you do
pick up something that's not in your
wheelhouse you can still get better at
it by just doing the thing
so if if i like i didn't have any
shotgun skills at all but if i picked up
a shotgun and started shooting it a
bunch you would rank up with the gun and
yeah it's it's kind of like skyrim where
the thing you do
you get better it's funny you mentioned
the cool thing because when i created my
character i dumped
all my points into cool right away and
the person i was playing with the dev
was like
may not want to do that and i was like
oh okay and i was like well
what if i want to play like a netrunner
so he had me spec into
intelligence and i think technical
ability was what it was called but what
i found out too
is cool is connected to stealth and i
ended up using a lot of stealth
because kind of like your guy's
experience i ended up being trash at net
running just because i didn't really
have many abilities unlocked
and i imagine that's going to be a
similar sort of experience for most
people who start this game
maybe not so much using firearms but i
think you're going to spec into
something
and then as you play you're going to
figure out how you actually want to
play at least early on it's important to
note that we played the first four or
five hours of the game
of like what is going to be like a 50 60
hour game so a lot of the stuff that
really will matter in the end um doesn't
really come into play
so like in the cool perk system there's
like a
it's like a cold blood like uh ability
so when you like
get super cool you have like uh buffed
abilities and that kind of stuff yeah i
i
the the small amounts of stealth that i
did manage to pull off was
quite interesting because it was like a
mixture of my stealth movement and also
using the
netrunner stuff um like hacking into a
camera
i i didn't realize that when you hack
into a camera they're very threatening
those cameras because they fire out
laser beams
and like it blankets the entire thing
and they move around and i was like
damn how do i even begin to do this and
i didn't realize that actually when you
hack into a camera you effectively take
it over and it's yours
but it doesn't change the red laser into
green to be like hey
you're green now it's good now it's a
good laser yeah it's a good laser so
like doing the small amounts of
i'm sneaking hacking that thing using it
to distract enemies the way like the two
different divergent styles of play kind
of meshed together
was really interesting so i'm looking
forward to see how they can be paired up
with like you know
netrunner's ability hacking abilities
with the stealth and then stealth's
abilities kind of complemented by the
you know
powerful gun kind of like spec and that
kind of stuff
that was the one thing almost every
encounter i started out by hacking into
the
local network or whatever it might be
and once you do that
you it basically when it highlights all
the different things you can hack which
i think because i was pretty early i
wasn't able to hack a lot but
there were like fans i could hack to
distract
enemies there were cameras you could
hack you could hack certain npcs too to
get other npcs to come by you could hack
grenades to make them explode
okay so we've talked about playstyle
we've talked about origin how about how
you guys just
kind of played this demo there was a lot
we could do they didn't really put any
restrictions
on us at all in terms of what we could
do uh
so how did you guys spend your four
hours my one was probably
the most plain playthrough in that i
jumped into it and
just kind of followed the main path and
quickly realized that it was
a familiar path i talked about this in
my written preview but it's
it's the a lot of it was the missions
that we saw in the
gameplay demos from the past two years
obviously this is the first time we've
actually played it for ourselves i think
the actual main path at least to start
with is a really good
um example of the different facets of
the gameplay mechanics like
that first mission you do with um for
dexter desean
you get a good flavor of what is hacking
like what is
uh combat like what is sneaking like and
you can start to figure out
i like i've got a feel for the hacking i
really like that so i'm gonna spec
towards that um and then i
used the kind of final moments to try
and find
some some like side quests that were
interesting the side quests are what
everyone loves from witcher so i wanted
one of those at least and i found that
yeah i mean i probably
took the exact opposite approach in that
i didn't even really do side quests i
just roamed the world
and messed around like the first thing i
did when i got out of these apartment is
i took i bought a knife
from uh the store called 21st amendment
and stabbed the cop
because i don't know he was out there
and i want to see what would happen
which is
something different from the witcher 3
right because well a there's no cops but
also
you can't just start destroying a town
in the witcher right because geralt is
this character who wouldn't do that
but in this uh you have that freedom
i gotta i forget how much the warrant
was and then
it was i got a notification saying the
the ncpd are now after me
and that was pretty interesting just
because i don't know immediately i
thought of gta
yeah like big gta vibes coming from this
game
uh you can also help the cops too like
you can go past
like a hold up or something and help
them out um there are a lot of
incidental things happening in the city
that you can just join in on
in fact the incidental stuff reminds me
a lot of red dead like you'd just be
walking around and there'd be a
firefight between cops and gangs and you
could
help out one of the sides you could just
walk away or sometimes there'd just be a
bunch of guys guarding
a cache or something and you could go in
kill them take it or occasionally with
your when you get your upgraded eye
i forget what they call it your upgraded
vision yeah you can actually see if
there's a warrant out on
npcs or and you can just examine them
and if you see warren out on this arrest
for this amount you can kill him and
you'll automatically get that money
transferred
into your account i i mentioned this to
jake earlier but i was doing some of
that kind of exploring
and found an incidental thing which was
a gang
fighting each other a couple of gangs
and i was like i'm just going to check
this out and the moment i realized i
should probably get on with my
my actual quest is when one of them
threw a grenade at another one another
one and missed completely and the
grenade just landed at my feet and i was
like
i'm i'm not here for this i'm out after
hearing about tomorrow's experience i
wanted to go see a lot more side quests
um but i think given that this is so
early in the game and the game actually
does want
to put you through those main quests to
get the breath of experience
there weren't that many other proper
side missions that i could do
the side quests that i did find did
look at sort of the kookier nature of
like the cyberpunk world
so one had you get into like a fight
club situation with these
twins who had uh merged their
consciousnesses to be
one person um and there's a lot of like
funny banter between them and like
stuff about them showing girlfriends and
that kind of stuff and basically you
just had to fight them both at once
and then there was another one where a
guy's
augmented penis had gone haywire and you
had to
rush him to the ripper dock basically
and like there's a whole bunch of
car banter in between there and so
that's that's kind of the the world
they're trying to set up and it's it's
not all
like grim dark uh cyberpunk stuff there
is a bit of a lot of levity in there i
think the most interesting
thing for me is how much the corporate
stuff played into the main quest
since my character came from a corporate
background like there's that whole thing
where one of your
uh contacts uh sets you up she gives you
like a
like a credit shipped with a virus to
like um
like sabotage the marauders uh basically
if you take the corporate path your
character basically knows all the [ __ ]
that she's gonna pull
you can just call her out on it and just
yeah just
basically you are in the position of
power there um which i found quite
interesting when i did that i
i decided to ignore her completely so
the in the original demos they do that
bit where they go to her
get the chip and then go to the
maelstrom gang and eventually things
kick off so i was like i'm gonna
just ignore that because i want to get
into it as quick as possible
um and the first thing i do when i meet
with the bad guy
uh is is or the gang leader is
shoot him in the head and kill him like
straight away because it's like
um you don't have the money to do
anything else or
your choices are either to kill him or
get killed
um and that knock-on effect is in the
original when you did the kind of
corporal route as well that dude would
get away
and then come back later with his
exoskeleton and fight you
this time around because he was dead
there was just no one in that area like
there was two guards who are just like
knocked out
i was like i'm out so like there is
there's like very
noticeable changes to what happens in a
mission depending on how
you do them in my playthrough i could
not
focus on the main path at all like
almost every
every corner i turned i was like oh this
looks interesting and i'd get out and
check it out just because the world is
so dense
but i found one small alley that opened
up into this
huge market place area where there are
all these characters wandering around
like it was packed
and there was a guy on the corner who
was like you know
he's a sidewalk preacher yelling about
how cybernetics
are destroying people and the next
generation needs to stop
uh cybering up their bodies so they can
so they can continue to live and and
whatnot
and i was watching him for a little bit
because i was just like ah sure and
two like trendy looking girls walked up
with phones
and immediately started like oh this is
the crazy guy everyone's been talking
about like
like let's get some pictures of them and
they start like taking selfies with them
and whatnot and he just keeps yelling
about it and he's getting frustrated and
i'm just sitting here watching this
whole thing play out
it is a very dense and distracting world
and
trying to block all that out and
actually look at the city for what the
city is like
is is very nice like i really
appreciated how
sort of it was built it's very it's got
a lot of verticality to it a lot of
stairs and like twisty pathways
there's like a lot of dead areas of the
city if you know what i mean like
because there are a lot of freeways
intersecting so there's obviously going
to be the quieter areas of the city
places that are a bit uglier yeah
because like it it makes the parts that
are bustling feel a little more real
when the stuff there's areas that aren't
like i had this one interaction which
stuck out to me
which i'm not sure if it was an accident
but i hope it wasn't but like
i was walking and i kind of drifted into
a an area of the pavement where there
was a cop nearby and he did not want me
to be there
and he very aggressively shouted like
back up
but next to me was a i'm not body
shaming or anything like that a very
large man was next to me
and i don't know what happened but like
he freaked out i just started running
and i was like okay i'm just gonna
follow this guy and i followed this guy
for
a while and he just kept running and it
wasn't like he was just running in a
straight line he was
he looked like he was going somewhere
and i was like i asked the developer i
was like is this
does this dude have a story and he was
like i'm not sure
um and i wanted to follow him because he
looked terrified and he just
he was like running he's i don't know
how he had that much stamina but i was
like
if this was if this was like my natural
play-through i think i would follow him
for about 15-20 minutes just to see what
would happen
but i think something else that really
stuck out that stuck out to me was the
brain dance mechanic
did you guys try that i did not know
yeah so that's something i didn't really
know about i've been kind of limiting
how much i see but
like at the risk of being reductive it's
the uh detective mode investigation
stuff from batman arkham origins um
i like to compare it to you did you guys
play tacoma the follow-up to god
that's exactly what it reminded me of so
just having a scene play out in 3d space
but you
are free to move around and look at the
other nooks and crannies not in the main
scene
so the idea is people are effectively
taking their memories
and um recreating them almost like in a
video editing suite
and then selling them on for various
things most of the time it's used for
you know adult entertainment but you can
do weird things with it and you can also
do things like
put yourself into another person's
memory and explore it
and you can do that via first person or
you can detach and just watch it all
play out
and then there's like wrinkles like um
using
just focusing on an audio layer in the
actual environment and listening to key
conversations
they show you how it works by uh making
you live through a failed
um hold up scene where one person is
where the perpetrator is
killed and you figure out why that
happened and how that happened and it's
just a really cool
wrinkle that makes me that makes me
excited about the potential for like
future cop and like the example that
they gave us
obviously very early and very linear and
i kind of am curious to see
whether the story changes based on what
you do or don't pick up like if you go
into a brain dance and don't pick up a
clue
uh what happens then yeah it's
impressive right
it's too bad most of the bds we do here
are only good for flogging the log in a
lot of ways it does
feel like an overall rpg that you know
players will probably be very familiar
with
yeah and it's more more like in-depth
than the witcher was
by design so like when i went into the
actual like
skill tree menu i was like wow this is a
lot and they were and the developer that
was on call was like
yeah people kind of felt like there
wasn't a lot of freedom to
create their own kind of geralt they
have buckets of like you know cool and
body and
you know tech and that kind of stuff but
with the in those there's like
multiple skill trees that have so many
different small options to unlock like
passives and abilities and that kind of
stuff
and for those that want it i did double
check and it seemed that
the developer on our on my playthrough
was like you can do a no kill run of the
game
so that's what i'll be doing well anyway
those are our impressions of cyberpunk
2077
we have a ton of cyberpunk content
planned and already up so make sure to
check
all that stuff out on gamespot and if
you have any questions for us we will be
doing a q a next week where we will
answer your questions
so if you have anything for us please
leave them in the comments below or you
can find us on twitter
and we will try to get to all those
questions next time anyway thank you so
much for watching and we'll see you
[Music]
later
you